non so se siete al corrente di che cosa
sia il black friday l'ultimo belardini
novembre di tutti gli anni si fa il
black friday che sarebbe questa giornata
dove le cose costano meno su amazon il
black friday lo fanno per tutta la
settimana invece che sono il venerdì
ogni volta con pro cagate quando c'è
back friday volevo fare una seconda
puntata di cose inutili che si comprano
su amazon che l'aveva già fatta una e
tempo fa mi volevo vedere se riusciamo a
trovare qualcosa di milk board da subito
icona tra l'altro la spedizione sia
velocissimo a faccia ruga bello
bellissimo
minchia volare aspettavo due stelle
addirittura ma quando io vi dico che nel
black friday si acquistano cose che
servono alla vita e tutti i giorni le
quale non potete fare a meno
non scherzo perché al modico prezzo di 8
dollari più 13 di spedizione abbiamo dei
golden lady gloves led keith haring
delle lampadine che ti infili nelle
orecchie per fare questo ea che cosa mi
chiami dovrebbe servire da c'è anche il
video fermi tutti
vi prego a non le hanno fatte vedere nel
video indossate perché si vergognavano
pure loro di metterle quindi ho detto
vabbè abbiamo un infant circoncisi un
trainer c'è praticamente un coso serve
alla gente per allenarsi e fare la
circoncisione dove posso prendere quello
nero perché c'è anche quello nero che
questo qua quando le luci sono spente
tutti quanti sono neri ben chiaro ho
preso questa roba mio cugino per natale
non faccio più parte della famiglia
fantastico fat old friends black 385
dall pantaloni sporchi li p.pio sporchi
di merda direttamente per il fatto che
quando vuoi in fingere di st cagato
addosso hanno davanti da ppe indietro di
fantastico c'è mica 23 fantastico
siccome ritrovi a meno in un sacco di
negozi di vestiti di cui non faccio i
nomi per evitare di essere denunciato un
barile di lubrificante da 55 galloni
barile di lubrificare cosa te ne fai di
un barile
griffin barile di boldi lubrificata
corpi grosso 1500 donne a massa che
lubrifica tutta la vita ti rubrica sma
per la nonna 27 dollari
deschamps bong che non è altro che un
bicchiere piegato
diversi l'acqua né la bevanda nel
bicchiere e succhi dalla parte opposta
ok attenzione attenzione finalmente
arriviamo negli articoli utili visto che
adesso non è che fossero una console da
dj per gatti cioè nel senso tu metti sta
roba per terra il gatto vali che gratta
e intona martin garics e torres
colorante per cessi cioè una luce
colorata per certi attacchi al cesso sta
roba eccesso ti diventa multicolor cioè
di quello che vuoi diventa blu verde
viola rosso già al rachel successo dei
medici come se non bastasse il cesso
anche il getto del lavandino colorato e
che ovviamente ci mancava vedo che
comunque nonostante il black friday
alcune offerte non sono il massimo tipo
dei sandali che sono gli stessi che ha
il tipo che sta in piazza del duomo che
ti lega e braccialetti al polso senza
che tu li chieda niente li troviamo su
amazon
alla modica cifra di 50 dollari 50
dollari ma avete una minima idea di che
cosa sia la moda chiara ferragni che i
1500 coccinelle vive cosa diavolo appena
lecce tu vuoi comprare
cosa puoi comprare 1500 coccinelle vive
e costano anche una sega della
gustosissima carne di unicorno unicorni
mito di avevo sin scontato grazie a dio
meno male black friday passa avevo già
anche visto nello sconto precedente ah
sì l'avevo visto sicuramente però mi
sembra vedi che sono torturati questi
poveri unicorni per farla carne di
unicorno diciamo no a questo scempio la
carne di drago c'è anche abb e meno male
meno male meno male però non possono
fare vedere queste immagini maledizione
per che maltrattano i poveri draghi per
prendere la carne in scatola maledizione
questo mondo vada rovina e mergers gli
under penso cioè biancheria di emergenza
cosa vuol dire se per caso ti trovi
senza mutande dice oh dio e tiri fuori
starhub spiega talking trump christmas
card quindi c'è donald trump che ti
augura buon natale che sarà strà
comprato soggetto tra l'altro si ecco
fantastico best seller densi bestseller
ed best dancing with kids ma crolla
perché best seller dio mio caso sto
leggendo giocava su kindle
va bene clay visions non aerobics atu
lanci la palla la devi prendere al volo
ma se i deve essere proprio un gioco da
premi nobel proprio ti danno
per per la scienza subito dopo che
riesce a centrare il coso con la palla
nel 2017 ci saranno gli over board
dicevano sì ci siamo dati siamo un passo
da quello proprio siamo così si sempre
te stesso a meno che tu non sia un
unicorno in quel caso sì un unicorno 8
dollari 79 poi ce n'è un altro che dice
prendiamoci tutti un momento per
ringraziare che i ragni non volano e a
parer mio ma è stata detta frase più
significativa di questa un corno
gonfiabile per il vostro gatto bene
anche questo non è niente male vedi come
sono contenti gatti di indossarlo amazon
mi sorprende sempre un pulsante con su
scritto stronzate che non credo faccia
nient'altro se non dire stronzate ogni
volta che lo schiacci 8 dollari groguhe
boyfriend cresce un ragazzo mettimi
nell'acqua lovetti nell'acqua e cresce
fantastico e c'è anche grugger friends
meraviglioso note lamenti nell'acqua
cresce raga io non ho trovato la
risoluzione tutti i miei problemi anche
quelli di papà vegas serial power delle
mani da mettere sulla mano in modo tale
da avere sei mani in un cappello questo
scritto faccio la pipì in piscina a 10
dollari questo mi sembra anche onesto un
sacco di merda 9 dollari un sacco di
merda ben sa chi piedi diete ma ad ora
ga fermi
ho visto a casa più [ __ ] della vita lo
voglio immediatamente non parlo della
tizia parlo di cose sotto c'è questa qua
l'avranno anche pagata per fare se poi
lo faccio gratis costa 620 dollari pre
veramente figo non saprai mai
nell'universo dove metterlo fare
veramente figo un asciugamano che si
affacciano scritto faccia a raina
asciugamano unico è divisa in due parti
una per la faccia e uno per il culo ma
fantastico cioè la vita non dovevo
neanche vi preoccuparci di ricordarci
quali sono gli asciugamani il sapone per
il culo e per la faccia c'è scritto
proprio sul sapone un temperamatite
fantastico questo questo è fantastico
anche free shipping grazie a dio il mio
morbido e soffice culo di gabriella
vitale bene fascia portabebè bellissima
la vendono già col biglietto di euro
verso il messico annesso dai ragazzi
dire che posso concludere qui a questo
punto l'unica roba che potrei prendere
un set di cerotti i propri piccoli
perché se mi faccio un taglietto così ma
che posso lamentarmi
le band e vabbè però che vi sia piaciuto
spero che anche per voi sia utile black
friday non riesco manco a dirlo è un
dizionario di inglese anche sarebbe
utile da comprare i ragazzi speravi
davis era uscito cose e mi piace anche
ai presa c'è come iscrizioni cosa questi
iscrivetevi e buone spese
spero bella ragazza
[Musica]